well first I will tell them or remind
them if they know a little bit that all
the method that we are around is
composite of atoms and the atoms are
kind of mini sort of system not quite
but nevertheless it's an image and in
the middle there is a nucleus which is
and and for a long time this was
supposed to hold atom to be not possibly
that it was not possible to cut it to
separate but now we know that it is an
inside the atom there are particles
which are called quarks and other
particles and all the kind which of the
constituent fundamental of matter which
what called elementary particle and
there are also other elementary
particles which are constituent of
things which are transmitted from one
object to another like photons which are
constituents of light and there are
other ones and some of this particle
have no mass and some heaviness photons
have no mass and the characteristic of
mass is normally when you push it it's
very difficult if it's a high mass is
very different to push it right but no
more detailed meaning of what it means
is that those particles which have known
us rather whatever you do with the same
velocity which is the velocity of light
right and particle which I have now
never reached the velocity of light so
the big distinction between the two now
the problem was that one did not succeed
to make a theory which could predict
what one could do with this element
ability
in particular we know that we can do of
them everything that is around us
whether it's that glass whether it's
television apparatus whatever right we
can do all of that but the recipe for
doing that was not really very well
known and one particular difficulty is
that one could imagine constructing a
recipe with woodwork if all the
particles which have no mass and if all
particles which have no mass then one
could indeed fall a formula which would
predict everything but that would result
in predicting nothing because after all
that is not the world we live in and so
we were obliged to invent how particles
which have no mass can acquire mass some
of them at least
and some novels right and for this we
imagined at that moment some particle
bosons and that condense to give kind of
a sea but the sea that exists all over
the universe so that every particle has
to go through it including ourselves
and so the elemental part that goes
through them can acquire a mass if they
are sensitive to this that is more
complicated to understand but the theory
predicts which are the particle which
will get a mass and those which will not
get a mass and that essentially
permitted to construct the recipe for
doing the thing and the important thing
of course is that from this condensation
it is possible to extract one particle
and test if the theory is correct and
that is what has been done at CERN now I
don't know
13 or 14 years roll will get something
but I hope they will at least get a
little bit interested